لا تدفع Google عادةً مقابل اللحاق بالركب ، لكن
Godzilla لمحركات البحث عبر الإنترنت
تفعل ذلك تمامًا مع إطلاق
برنامج الدردشة الآلي الجديد للذكاء الاصطناعي
المسمى Bard لتجربة
chatbot الجديد ، حيث يمكن للمستخدمين الاشتراك في
قائمة الانتظار التي يتم طرحها أولاً في
الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة ولكن من المفترض أن تنافس دردشة
GPT ولكن Google تقر ولكن لا يزال
لديها الكثير لتتعلمه وتقول إن
التعليقات المستمرة من الخبراء والمستخدمين ستساعد في
تحسين الاستجابات.
ينضم إلينا من سان فرانسيسكو ، مرحبًا بك
مرة أخرى ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لاستضافتي ، حسنًا ،
إليك جزء من البيان الذي جاء
من Google حيث قاموا بفتح Bard لعدد
محدود من المستخدمين.
بدون
أخطاءهم على سبيل المثال لأنهم يتعلمون
من مجموعة واسعة من المعلومات التي
تعكس تحيزات العالم الحقيقي والصور
النمطية التي تظهر أحيانًا في
مخرجاتهم ويمكنهم تقديم
معلومات غير دقيقة مضللة أو خاطئة أثناء تقديمها
بثقة وأنا أعلم أن كل شيء عن ذلك
منتج جديد مع
إخلاء مسؤولية يشير إلى أنه ليس
جاهزًا تمامًا لـ Prime Time لا
يشير إلى الكثير من الثقة في كل هذا
في الوقت الحالي ،
فأنت تعلم أن Google bard تم تسميته على اسم
الشعراء والمغنين القدامى الذين اعتادوا
سرد تلك القصص البذيئة مثل
William  شكسبير ولكن لا تتوقع
الحصول على أي شيء حار جدًا من
ردودها ، تخشى Google بشدة أن
تتعرض علامتها التجارية للتلطيخ بسبب إساءة استخدام
Ai ، ولهذا السبب كلما وضعت
سؤالاً في صندوق Bard ، فإنه
يمنحك في الواقع ثلاثة ردود على نوع من
يحد من مسؤوليته
ويتنصل باستمرار من أنه لا يجب عليك
النظر في هذا بحثًا عن الحقائق جيدًا ، فقد
يكون مفيدًا لسحب
مجموعة من الآراء أو جمع
المعلومات معًا إذا كنت تريد حقيقة معينة ،
فقد لا تعمل بشكل جيد.  هو
بالضبط ما حدث في
الإطلاق المحرج لـ Google bard
الشهر الماضي عندما ظهرت لأول مرة وحصلت على
إجابة خاطئة أمام الجميع
ولكن ما زلت أعتقد أن هذا
مثير على الرغم من أننا أخيرًا
لدينا منافسة تعرفها بعد
سن  الاحتكار في التكنولوجيا حيث تعلم أن
Facebook يحكم شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
ويوجد بحث محكوم بجوجل لدينا
منافسة حقيقية في سوق الذكاء الاصطناعي والتي
تفيد المستخدمين بقدرات أفضل
وتفيد الشركات الناشئة حيث أنهم جميعًا يتنافسون على
تقديم أفضل منصة مطورة